this is Joe mankiewicz in New York and  now from London on film a nominee for  her performance in love is a  many-splendored thing miss Jennifer  Jones  everyone in the profession knows what  this is that holy of Holy's the  director's chair however it is rarely  used because most directors are too  frantically busy to sit down they have  to be for no film can be successful  without the hard work of a talented and  understanding director this year five  gifted directors have been nominated and  now if someone will please open the  envelope we shall learn which of them is  the winner  the directors nominated our Elia Kazan  for East of Eden Joshua Logan for picnic  government for Marty David Lean for  summertime on Sturgis for bad day at  Black Rock the winner here in New York  is down my ankle Mattie  I do thank you very much